So now let's talk about mass
shootings. Mass shootings, right? So
get rid of gun free zones.
No one wants to hear that.
Get rid of gun free zones.
If you're not going to
establish a perimeter outside
of a building where I can
go, don't tell me I can't
bring my gun in there.
A sign on the window is not stopping
somebody from coming into the building.
We've seen it time and time
and time and time again.
If the guns were the problems,
we would have mass shooting at every
gun show every single day. But we don't.
Why the same reason you
pointed out why that one,
that one place in Georgia when they
said everybody had to have a gun,
crime went down.
People don't want to hear that though.
They don't want to hear the answer to
gun violence is everyone has a gun.
No, not such a convenient answer for
a guy like you is very convenient.
So many guns you can't count. But
here, let's look at the alternative.
We've been living in it, right? Right.
And we knowledging that there's a problem,
right? So why are we entertaining? In the
fact that maybe that is the case, right?
But do you think that like
school shootings, for example,
do you think that these teachers
being armed and would be the answer?
I all right, so, or do you think there
should be armed security on the campus?
I say it should be multilayered,
right? Because if you,
if you really want to put
things into perspective,
and the NRA didn't add about this and
people got pissed off, but it's the truth.
Wherever whatever school the president's
kids go to, they are guarded by guns,
right? That school was
protected by guns, right? Right.
Anything we hold valuable in this
country is protected with guns.
No one is more anti gun than Hollywood.
When you hear about any sort
of crime or gun violence,
the left wing people in
Hollywood are the most vocal,
the most virtue signaling the quickest
to jump on their pedestal. Meanwhile,
what percentage of their fucking
movies involve gun violence?
And if you look at the Academy Awards,
did you see the security at
the Academy Awards? Right?
You see all these left leaning liberal
actors being protected by people at flak
jackets on carrying guns with
fingers outside the triggers. I mean,
dogs, it's crazy. You
know what it is though.
It's a loss of touch with reality.
Well,
they're also insulated and
protected. Well, that's part
of it because in her mind,
their mindset goes like this.
Well, I have security guards.
I mean Kim Kardashians,
the biggest,
I did a video on that. So I had to have
his first thing that came to Vegas.
What she biggest apricot on
that. Right. Because she's a
dumb dumb. Yeah, of course.
But she's, she also influences
a ton of people. Yeah.
That's unfortunate. But exactly.
Steve Harvey had her on family feud.
They were on family feud,
the Kardashians and the West.
We're talking about how fucking stupid
kid was. But we know this though.
That's the crazy thing. She, there's
no incentive for to be intelligent.
There isn't, I mean, she's good at
making money. Oh absolutely. Yeah,
absolutely. And I don't
fault her for that. Hey, make
your money. But, but people,
but at the end of the day, you still,
she still has access to scores of young,
influential minds. I understand that.
That's unfortunate, but it's not,
and we can do about that.
There isn't,
but other than you point out the fact
that she's a dumb dumb. Pretty much. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. It's not terrible person.
I don't know. I don't know the woman.
I just don't, well, I've heard a talk.
I just don't think she's really
interested in expanding your mind.
I just don't think that that's something
that's not benefits. But that's her.
Here's the thing about the mindset though,
is there are people who
we paid to carry guns.
Right? I don't need to carry
them. Therefore you don't either.
So you're saying about her
is that she is anti gun,
she talks about being anti gun,
yet she's constantly surrounded by
people who have guns. That's a fact.
Absolute fact.
So you cancel this fact,
so then you can't turn around and tell
me that no, you don't need a firearm.
Right.
Of course you don't.
Just seven foot tall dudes strapped
to the fucking gills all around you.
Yeah. Yeah. So it, it's, it's man,
it's frustrating because it's like,
I get it.
I would love to have a dude standing
out here with ar 15 slung over their
shoulders ready to protect me. How to
give a notice when I could afford it.
I pay for it,
not do it.
The funny thing is I still carry a
gun on me because they can't always be
exactly where I am. Right.
You know what I mean?
That's a paranoid way to live though,
isn't it?
What difference does it make you think
about it? How much does it affect me?
I wake up everyday,
put a gun on my hip and go out and do
the exact same thing I would do if I
didn't have it. But you don't
think about it. So in the,
in a sense you feel like
you're not paranoid. I'm not
paranoid. No, there's no, no,
no,
no more paranoid than any than any person
that has a fire extinguisher in their
house. Think about it. It's a, it's like
I don't walk around like, Oh my God,
I'm my God, who's, who's coming
to get me? That's paranoia. What,
what all I'm doing is being
prepared, right? Well,
there could be levels of preparedness.
You start to hit diminishing returns.
Where starts to be like, it starts to
take away from your quality of life,
but me putting a gun on my hip
and just go on about my business,
that doesn't interfere with my
life enough to say, you know what,
and it's not quite worth it.